I don't want any I don't want any was
there oh my god hello everybody my name
is markiplier and welcome to re 77 now
it is very confusing for me because
there was no title screen on this game
and I just loaded up waking up here in
what can only assume as a bed and might
be s I'm playing okay hello hi oh hello
hi do I want to go out there oh that's
probably important can I have that
middle mouse to zoom ye okay wait did I
get oh I did get it oh hello hi oh this
is lovely and bye lovely I mean
horrifying whoa whoa I just noticed that
it's like an impression to me in the bed
it's kind of like the opening a portal
to okay so that means I've been here a
long time long enough for the paint to
start peeling off the walls hello oh oh
what a bright beautiful day and there's
bars on the window is that to keep me in
or to keep other people out where'd my
flashlight go there it is oh jeez oh
jeez hello princess how are you doing oh
oh oh I love the art pitch black like my
soul oh and it x marks the spot
apparently okay oh okay nevermind then
I'll go the other way
supposedly that's gonna be better for me
hello
mmm this looks fun I know I'm gonna have
a good time here I know everybody
involved is gonna have a good time Oh at
least this is art hello was I say 9 I
don't know what that number is but it's
1947 and I believe that's a 9 at the
beginning is that important it's not
gonna come into play later in the game
and I think your paintings upside down
not to criticize your artistic choices
oh is this game inspired by PT cuz that
this looks a lot like PT this is like
isn't it isn't that like the exact same
like way it was a stairwell down wasn't
it ooh oh okay oh good oh good
oh good Oh oh yeah oh yeah the ball
changed colors I think okay so it is
gonna be kind of a looping hallway style
PT thing is that gonna be any more clear
no there any more writing on the wall
that I need to be aware of hello another
X okey-dokey then
I can't wait for things to go
topsy-turvy all over me hi why'd you do
that oh that hurts my eyes
I'm getting out here who tried to kill
me with light darkness is my only friend
okay hello ah good yes very good very
good
is it getting darker I have a funny
feeling it's getting darker Oh were you
there before oh I don't remember looking
at these but then again I might have
just missed it but I don't think all
this was was this here before I don't
quite remember it oh boy oh boy oh boy
hoo hoo doggy okay
well alright then ah yes good why do I
need to sprint why do I need to do how
to sprint relay slit
I don't like it what games do that give
a nice subtle soft hint that I need to
sprint holy [ __ ] oh god no no I don't
want to do this oh man I love the
interior decorating you've done is there
any like clue here I'm not very
observant in these things some many
times I'll I'll miss something ooh okay
crumpled up paper is important no yes
maybe a lot of footprints on the floor
I'll put principle hey hey hey why is
that moving
what the [ __ ] was that
why something why's a log need to go
zooming by my head who's doing lumber
work upstairs oh good I'm glad I'm onna
Oh
why am i doing that why am i doing that
that's not normal
is that why my head shaking spastically
I think my shadows moving a little more
than my head is good god that's
terrifying as horrifying oh my god what
is going on why is bouncing up against
the princess door was that where it was
I need to go back in line
OOP need to go back to my room yet still
time to play oh boy
okay oh geez oh geez oh geez I know
where I gotta go now
oh geez well gee Scoob
what's that luck to doing is this where
I need to learn to sprint he learned his
bread oh good okay it's printing goodbye
Ruby please was that plan always there
that plant was not always there
wait a minute someone's [ __ ] with me
this plant was not here what's going on
wait a minute someone is expressly
[ __ ] with me I feel patently dict
with oh come on oh don't be like that oh
don't be like that you're not just gonna
send me back and forth on a loop are you
that plan was not there I know for a
fact I may be unobservant but I think
I'd noticed a plant suddenly appearing
okay what do I gotta go
that's nothing okay I thought I saw
something oh come on
what am I supposed to do am I supposed
to loop back and forth forever with my
shaky head and my shaky but why am i
going so slow why am I going so slow oh
that's low I can't run anymore why okay
I don't know why that happened
oh oh oh hello can i Wow is why is it so
dark why it's so dark why what is
happening did I do something okay what
happened what huh what's it having anger
the [ __ ]
after toggle flash I don't wanna
oh oh oh yeah that's nice oh this is
better
oh this is so much better okay so I was
looping back and forth making up my own
clues forever and ever like an idiot
when in reality I was supposed to do a
thing I did not realize that
[ __ ] off no thank you I don't want any
hello okay ah no thank you
so in my imagination I created a clue
out of a plant a bone that I didn't
notice and everything and I was running
back and forth for a while like an idiot
when when in reality I wasn't supposed
to do that
I don't want anything I don't want any I
don't want any I don't want any was
there I [ __ ] up no okay well at least my
flashlights back to normal and the ball
is over there for some reason so the
trick was zooming in I don't know if I
actually mentioned that so I needed to
zoom in so I saw that's what I forgot
from the beginning of the game was the
whole zooming aspect of it well Oh
libecki Oh oh yeah why that's not normal
how am I supposed to do about that I
don't think I'm supposed to do anything
about that oh I think I need to stop
that oh geez is that just gonna keep
oozing oh so easy oh so easy okay welp
nope can't do anything about it
well I guess I'll just carry on wherever
the hell else I'm supposed to go in this
game
can I go down the hallway now or am I
stuck in here again why oh oh
progress my god beautiful beautiful
progress oh I can't wait to have my soul
ripped out from my heart was it raining
still goopy still nice and goopy alright
okay so everything seems about the same
Oh - Oh what is that they're a real add
they're watching us okay who and why and
how
so is this special in any ie
I feel a lot better
should I look at the bone nope that
bones not interesting enough okay bye
I'm gonna go now away from you oh man
this game oh hello Oh something seems
different something seems is it even goo
oh it's even goofier than before
great I was hoping for a buncha extra
goop well I need in my life shut the
[ __ ] up shut up you're doing that huh
some burnout me crying you know what I
knew to people that cry and cry with
them then I cry harder and I beat him at
their own game of crying like a [ __ ] no
one cries like marquise moon okay
alright okay alright
okay well this seems roughly the same as
before am I supposed to do a thing oh
that's that's Pleasant that's Pleasant
that is that's nice and pleasant oh boy
I have a funny feeling that it's gonna
loot me through the same section until I
figure out what to do you're in there
it's gonna keep looping for a bit I
guess different color again is a
different color that's like [ __ ] you
okay you think you just do that huh you
think that's loud
well I guess that's the end of that it's
just the demo or pre-alpha I don't know
it's early so that what sorry 77
I got spooped so anyway this game was
actually really like really really well
made I mean there's been a lot of games
that try to be PT this is by far the
closest I mean it was a bit hard to
figure out just because I was an idiot
but that doesn't mean that it was any
sort of bad it got me in this mode where
I was looking at desperately for
everything and I was making things out
of nothing and that's cool that's
something you very rarely see in a game
where you're so engrossed in what it is
that you're trying to come up with any
way to rationalize what's happening so
either way now was this game let me know
what you thought of it down in the
comments below and thank you everybody
so much for watching
and as always I will see
in the next video by